[Music]
what if one day you turned on the news
channel to see this news volcanic
eruption already caused 2 million
casualties or Airport are closed if all
the volcanoes on earth erupted at once
what our planet survived all the ash
molten lava and scorching gases how far
up into the atmosphere would the ash go
would there be anyone left to report the
news this is what if and here's what
would happen if all the Earth's
volcanoes erupted at once not all
volcanoes would pose a danger extinct
volcanoes those that haven't erupted in
the last 10,000 years just don't have
any magma left to erupt again however at
any given time there are 10 to 20
volcanoes erupting somewhere on earth in
total there are 1,500 active volcanoes
on land and an unknown number of them
underwater what if all of them are uptil
dat once
what would this apocalypse look like
exactly if all active volcanoes on earth
went off at the same time there would be
a lot of explosions explosive eruptions
would churn out walls of rocks ash and
gas wiping out the nearby areas you
wouldn't be able to out drive that giant
hot cloud rocks as hot as 1000 degrees
would be traveling faster than 700
kilometers an hour
but not all volcanoes would erupt that
powerfully instead of violently
expelling magma some volcanoes would
steadily eject it onto the ground
that's called an effusive eruption if
your local volcano erupted that way
consider yourself lucky but not for too
long
other eruptions would be sending plumes
of ash up into the air
these would travel for thousands of
kilometers and cover the earth with a
thick blanket of ash a chic Louds would
block the sunlight plunging the whole
planet into complete darkness without
sunlight there's no chance of
photosynthesis all the plants would die
including all the crops that feed us in
the animals because volcanic ash is
actually tiny rock particles it would be
very heavy if enough ash were to fall on
your roof your home would collapse and
you're not escaping this in an airplane
the hot clouds of ash would melt car and
plane engines all flights would be
canceled anyway because of the low
visibility deep ocean volcanoes make the
water acidic in this kind of environment
sea life would suffer huge losses the
entire food chain would be devastated
because no sunrays would reach the
Earth's surface the planet would
significantly cool down to the point
where we might end up in a new ice age
in the long term know the global
temperatures would change again this
time getting much hotter with all the
carbon dioxide released during the
eruptions we'd see a tremendous
greenhouse effect that would start
roasting the planet now if you survived
the volcanic explosions and didn't die
from breathing in the ash the safest
place for you might be on a ship in the
middle of the ocean or in an underground
bunker just make sure you have enough
food supplies and warm clothes to keep
you alive in this post-apocalyptic world
before coming out you'll need to wait
until the atmosphere clears up that's
going to take a very very long time and
you wouldn't be seeing the earth you
once knew prolonged volcanic eruptions
spewing from the planet's mantle would
dump this partly molten layer on the
surface causing a mass imbalance as a
result our planet might tip over just
like Mars did about three and a half
billion years ago Paris might end up on
the North Pole of course as always such
a scenario is very
likely to happen at least there's no
evidence of all volcanoes erupting at
once in the 4 billion year history of
Earth but is it better to be prepared
for everything
[Music]